ils travaillèrent ball sonar ou est à
moscou pour rencontrer vladimir poutine
une visite en pleine crise autour de
l'ukraine le président brésilien est
arrivé hier soir les discussions portent
sur les relations bilatérales entre les
deux pays avec deux des sujets brûlants
à l'international selon le kremlin on va
rejoindre à notre correspondante à
moscou maylis déstresse
maylis bonjour alors que retenir des
pourparlers entre d'ailleurs molson
arrow et vladimir poutine
en entretien constructif et productif
selon les deux chefs d'état vladimir
poutine a souligné que les positions
russes et brésiliennes sont proches
voire coincide sur un grand nombre de
questions internationales écoutez
bien sûr nous poursuivrons une
interaction active avec nos partenaires
brésiliens dans le cadre du bri une
association internationales influentes
qui occupe une place importante dans le
monde multipolaire moderne et joue un
rôle considérable dans l'économie
mondiale
un avis partagé par son homologue
brésilien qui a mis en exergue les
valeurs communes partagées par la russie
et le brésil
sont morts les dalles
nous sommes solidaires de tous les pays
qui désirent et font tout leur possible
pour parvenir à la paix ils sont peints
par la passe
nous travaillons en étroite
collaboration au sein de plateformes
internationales telles que les brics le
g20 et l'ol nul
j'ai fini en défendant le droit
souverain à l'autodétermination et en
respectant la charte des nations unies
et le droit international
il s'agit de la première visite de
germolles sonar ou en russie depuis son
entrée en fonction en 2019 une visite
qui ne plaît guère aux états unis compte
tenu de la crise ukrainienne
washington aurait d'ailleurs exerçait
des pressions sur le chef d'état pour
que celui-ci annuler son déplacement
selon le vice-président brésilien ce
matin ce sont les ministres russe et
brésilien de la défense et des affaires
étrangères qui se sont entretenus lors
d'une rencontre au format 2 + 2 inédite
pour les deux pays
merci beaucoup à vous malisse d'estrées
pour tout fait acision direct depuis
moscou